hello
hi
[Music]
i bang my head
what's up chat
oh
what's up atomic hi stan hi pascal
what up papa
whoops i messed up
there we go
i'm back like i promise bloggers
welcome back is it even possible without
running ruining another's quest i don't
know
we're certainly going to try
we may find that we can't even do this
oh okay i'm going to ask chat this do we
do storm veil
or do we go south
i think we should go to castlemore
actually
we gotta go to irena
edgar
all that
i
would not do that atomic
i figured it was a joke
the lows some hungita i think we should
go south that's like kind of makes sense
for where we should go
watch your new video you did a good job
with it thank you
i wish i didn't have to make that video
because this whole situation frankly
sucks and i hate it
but here we are
dealing with
it what up dan
do i have any upgrades
not really did i go in the cave
over here
no
oh i know who to talk to
i need to go in the cave first
we shouldn't go straight south yet
i'm sorry i had to go through that it's
okay man
i i appreciate the support on the whole
situation it has been
it has been exhausting
no
he has not responded to the counter
claim
i don't know how he could
because
he would have to get a lawyer
and i'm pretty sure any lawyer would
look at this situation and
say like
you shouldn't do this
but
who knows
i know
and all the people who have because i'm
still getting tons of dms
saying like
that i'm wrong and that i plagiarized
and that i'm i'm a horrible person or
whatever
the only thing they ever say is that
is that i plagiarized which is
for one not true but they can believe
what they want to believe on that
and then
they just say they just say that right
and it's like you do realize that at
this point it's not even about that
like once you filed a copyright claim
this is now a legal issue
i have consulted
i i have a lawyer and i've consulted my
lawyer
and he says it's ridiculous and that a
judge would likely throw this away on
site
so
i am very confident
but he also
seems confident somehow i don't i don't
know how
sir i need that
oh these guys are bad for this
we made this run through here
katanas are not good against these guys
but we do need these
mr losem dongita
as a lawyer
yeah it's a comment on reddit
also
like
i made this point in the video
which is
let's say i did
let's say i did plagiarize the entire
thing
it's still not copyright which is what
they aren't understanding
[Music]
oh i'm dead
we're dead
we're alive
we're dead
no i didn't kill europe it's in uh um
it's in a cave
pretty close to here
or a dungeon
i i do not think he's going to take this
situation to court i truly don't
i truly don't
but um he's clearly a very
like
he just doesn't understand anything
apparently and he thinks he's right
but
so so that's what i mean like he who
knows right
[Music]
uh i made a video on it it's my most
recent video if you want to see
yeah it's an uchi i don't this is i
think uh yura's katana is like way
longer right
actually yeah let's keep that up there
yeah i don't know how people are
defending it i well the people who are
defending it are just hell bent on that
i plagiarized
and like i can tell them that i didn't
as many times as i want and they will
not listen to that
so it's like pointless to even try and
talk to them
i think he's just trying to get
attention
that's all
and i'm just dealing with this because
it's a legal issue now
stay over there
stay
okay
i think we jump right here
yeah this whole thing has been uh
i missed it this whole thing has been
exhausting
to say the least
he he believes that
when he types a comment on reddit
that it is now his property
that's what he believes
it's clearly not true
but that's what he thinks that's who
we're dealing with
is that he now owns the words to that
comment
which saying out loud sounds ridiculous
but that is what he thinks and continues
to say
well he's mad that i didn't give credit
to him terrell
i gave credit to practical meat
which is where i heard the theory from
originally
he's mad that i didn't
uh quote his or credit his comment
that i never saw
and he just will not believe me when i
say i never saw it
because it is very similar
it is not the same but it is very
similar
it's just a giant coincidence that he
can't accept
troll
no i can't hit his head
what is this
dead
has anyone ever used the roar medallion
because i have not
yeah everything belongs to from software
and that's very obvious but from
software doesn't give a [ __ ]
obviously
that's not the point he think he he
thinks that he owns the words that he
put on reddit which is not true but
that's what he thinks
he sent me all the links to why he
believes all this stuff
um he just didn't read
everything
i talked about it all in the video
i seem like a very hard hard boss
well i came here like way later
so did i fight the dragon yet
did i fight the dragon
the answer is
what
what just happened
okay
it's good for strength builds and
colossal weapons oh okay cool cool cool
cool cool
well
let's go get those back
three
where are my runes
aha
yeah the animation got me
pain
did he just go into the ground
hi kyle
how's your day
oh i rolled your forehead
[Music]
fire
man
that timing is so hard
what is that what
this dragon's being weird
oh i'm dead
i'm alive
i forgot i need to go to the left there
are you not staggered yet my man
oh
damn
there we go
easy peasy
make that into a youtube short did i
fight the dragon yet
true
the least enjoyable fishing trip in
history
facts
so new character i'm still using my
first one he's level 187 nice
i think my first character is like 2
200 something
i'm letting chat choose the build zoot
so as we go along i'll just like ask you
guys like what you would want
right now we're just trying to survive
i could so based on what my lawyer said
i could counter sue him for defamation
and harassment
and illegal copyright obviously
so there's that
club and no armor
so
a wretch
is what you're saying
where is the um
i forget her name where is she
i'm dead
but would you though um if he took if he
takes the next step to take this to
court i would 100 countersue him
yes
i would clean him out
i will is her name selling
should we do it let me solo her
she's near the flower right where's the
flower
sir you're annoying and i'm gonna kill
you now
yay
i mean
yeah it is what it is i did not start
this entire thing and he wanted it to be
public from the beginning so
here we are
all i tried to do is dm him and he just
never answered he even told me like i'm
not gonna answer your dms i'm just gonna
i'm only gonna answer you in a public
thread because it should be public i'm
like all right here we go
pretty much
dragon incantations
i've never used those actually that
could be fun
rip wolf
why am i like it's around here right am
i tripping
it's over here
found it
the amps are still technically public
yeah ethically they're not but if he
wanted it to be public
here we go
just what happened
full dragon build this is gonna suck
because i have no health
[Music]
never mind
these guys ever stop attacking oh my god
how
this sucks
these things don't stagger i don't think
i might die here
which would be balls
no
dang it
what's to stop him or her to post it
after you talk with them in dms i mean
nothing
i did
in my video i showed our dms
i died
pain
it is amazing how generous the uh
statues of america are like in the
beginning areas
very generous
pumpkin head is a menace
god
these things are hard to fight
i keep hitting this helmet man
yeah they might be generous everywhere
there we go
easy peasy
even though i died
yep that is true high quality
loss of income
harassment defamation
um
i mean harassment being that he openly
tried to uh
like have people message me
on reddit and then people on reddit went
obviously to like youtube and discord
and twitter and everywhere to
say all that or to
just flame me basically
which is why in my video i put a
disclaimer please don't do that where he
did not do that and clearly did not want
to do that so
that's harassment dog
the australian part of the map has a lot
of sacred tiers
australia
low tarnished are we
yeah no wonder you should turn up here
i am selling a sorcerer quite plainly
why are you here
it was very close happy i i like i said
in the video i was very surprised by how
close it was but the reason that it is
close is because we're talking about the
same thing and the way to describe it is
the same breakdown
so
there like i had not even heard that
theory from this person's comment i had
already heard it from
many other youtube videos reddit posts
twitter's like uh tweets
everywhere the per like this person's
claiming that he owns words
to something that people have been
saying
for weeks before he did
and he just thinks that the words he
posted to reddit are now
copyrightable which is just
very interesting thinking
a yen for glenstone sorceries
i dare say your proclivities are [ __ ]
up
go check the most recent post
and then a lot of like when i say that a
lot of people are just gonna be like
yeah i'm not gonna believe that that's
totally fine you can believe me or not
i know what i did and i didn't
plagiarize anybody
and i'm not gonna be intimidated into
just like saying like
something that isn't true
which is what they're trying to do
he proved that to me in dms which is
ridiculous
he is not a youtuber to my knowledge i
don't think so
let me reconsider
well you are a piece of work
very well
you are now my protege stone sorcerer oh
caleb is florida
deep south lim grave is australia
got it
anticipate grievances
young apprentice thank you for all the
subs too we got 30 000 subscribers last
night chad thank you very much
i really appreciate that
i mean here here's the biggest thing is
that
he he's angry because he believes what
he believes
and that's that's fine like he can be
mad he can do all of that he can say
that i he can say that i play drives he
can say whatever he wants that's fine
but
when you copyright strike my channel
that's where you take this from
your own opinion on an ethical issue
and now you've made it a legal issue
you guys see what i'm saying
does that make sense hopefully
i have a scroll
is that a scroll
takes me back to my academy days
very well
this is sorcery with which i'm not
entirely unfamiliar
i'll be sure to incorporate it into one
of your lessons
never lose that inquisitive spirit my
apprentice
okay
she really takes you on like so fast
i haven't really done a magic build
i don't know i'm gonna keep going with
the katana for now
my armor sucks clearly
need to get three scrolls i've never
done her quest line so we're gonna have
to figure that out but as long as we
initiated it right there we're good
um
now i think we can go south
yes you can do polls on youtube i
believe it's at the bottom of the screen
i don't know if you have it
but i do
it's not betting though like on twitch
ah i wasn't looking
okay we already did that up there with
blight
so now we're going to irina
and edgar
edgar
i did not
get the chain mail armor now
oh i forgot to put chat on the screen i
feel like i should do that
i know someone suggested that last
stream and i it could be a good idea
what's up jack
hit the road jack
back to that
magic deck his dex is fun as hell
we'll see you'll see
no seeds
oh
there are a lot of flasks out here that
we can get which we will but
let's do this
yeah that ballista hits me sometimes and
other times it does not do anything
it was me oh well i forgot sorry
been dealing with some [ __ ] recently
been slightly distracted my name is
arena
i've escaped from castle mourn to the
south
the servants there have rebelled
i
i can't be sure what it is do you guys
think that um this area of elden ring is
the most boring
from all over
like the area to the south in castlemore
i find it the most boring area in the
game
hit the road jack yeah everybody sings
when you do that i
i fear for father's life
yeah isn't this hyeato
filled with hatred for everyone because
hayata only shows up after irena dies
they haven't spared a soul to help
finance your lawyer
joel thank you for the two dollars man
that will uh that will very much help
thank you
thank you man
even if his honor should be the price
please thank you thank you i just want
him to be safe
thank you
i love the misbegotten boss fight i love
it
but i think the area is the most boring
deliver it to my father who remains in
the castle hayata stole her body
cool
i haven't done that quest line yet
okay i think that's it
[Music]
you guys want to do dragon coal
incantations that sounds kind of dope
i love whacking that guy's knee
my knee
my leg
uh i did it should be at the bottom of
the screen kyle it is for me i don't
know if it is for you
i have no idea
do you need to kill melania
to finish millicent's questline
i don't think so
no
no no
pop
yeah this wait i don't have the map i
was going to show the map
this whole area out here is pretty i i
like it but it you know
compared to the rest of the game i think
it's the most boring
for me
maybe it's designed for people to level
up against margaret that's actually a
good point
because it's definite like this is one
of the easier areas as well
i just wonder why why they thought that
people would migrate to the south off
the bat
i mean i did
so
it's true
we want all those i wouldn't mind
getting this armor right here too it's
pretty good but
we'll come back
oh sorry
frenzy village and weep lean is cool but
it's a lot smaller than the lurinia one
yeah isn't it over here actually
aren't there like crazy rats over here
what is that
oh
that's a
pig hello
yellow ember see crazy rats
very small
is it up there
[Music]
let's go explore
this is an area i have not
looked at very much
[Music]
ah
there's a church in here
never been here
first time 300 hours never been here
owie
mommy
stop it
yeah i want to read that item
description
whoa whoa whoa whoa hey hey hey
okay dude
this is getting out of hand
can't kill each other
this is bad
terrible
dude i hate rats i hate them
i'd rather fight melania than a rat
huh
nice
yeah what did i what did i pick up what
was that item
was it a yellow ember
amber taken from the eye sockets of a
corpse material used for crafting items
a sign that the deceased suffered from
the flame of frenzy
this grape has ripened and burst ah it's
another grape it's just a dried up
stupid raisin
interesting
secrets here
oh
that's where the flame of frenzy is
originating from the maddening three
fingers causes the yellow flame of
frenzy to burst forth in the caster's
eyes charging increases the range of the
burst the flame of frenzy deals damage
and causes buildup of madness
this incantation also causes buildup of
madness in the caster
and only effective against tarnished
interesting
we gotta tear
is there more
whoa
i always found this area so boring so i
never explored it
is he just tripping oh
[Music]
oh my
[Music]
yeah
that is true isa
is a shield in here
are they frozen
this is really creepy
who are these
just people
beast repellent torch
flame crest wooden shield
that's cool
not a big shield guy but that is cool
yeah but that's what he thinks
isa
i don't know why he thinks that though
that's that's where i'm like weirded out
is because he firmly believes that he
does
firmly
so i just i just don't understand
oops
this area is cool i like it
now it's not as boring
map i haven't gotten the map yet but
it's uh pretty
it's like to the
south
and then a little bit to the east
rat
ratatouille
renny remy
is that all that's here though
oh
nice
thank you mackenzie i appreciate that
thank you for the kind words
you all seen ratatouille i hope
i really hope you all have seen
ratatouille bro that would be a crime if
you have not seen that movie
what the heck oh i thought they were
vultures for a second
it's castle mourn guys it's like what
oh i hate no i'm i ain't even dealing
with that nope no shot bucko
sick
what
oh i forgot i rested
it's like why are they back what the
hell
oh
okay
yeah they're the misbegotten yes
um
[Music]
wow
oh i've been here i'm silly it's right
here yeah
i think everyone was oh wrong one
can farm them for run arcs i am not
gonna cap with you guys i don't know if
i'm the only one
i quite literally have never used a
runarch
not a single time
let's go fight this queen
yo
bleed
whoa
now they're all going to back off
back off back off
back off move it
that's what i thought
let me take that from you real quick
nerd
that's how you handle that right there
i've not used a runark once in my first
playthrough and want my second cause i'm
on malketh
malketh is tough
[Music]
i still think melania is the hardest
boss
definitely
but malacath
yeah it really doesn't encourage the use
of like rune arcs which is essentially
the same as an ember
from dark souls right
any new secrets i just found a village
that i've never seen before
so that was cool
had the flame a frenzy in it
i used um i used my mimic stomach summon
my first playthrough because it was just
so overpowered
she uses a very specific
called yeah [ __ ] exactly
nice
um
it this is also weird like why did they
put a church right here with a with a
sacred tear right
and then you look out this way
and there's another church right over
there where you could you can just ride
straight there and get another sacred
tier
we're kind of getting op really quick
yeah ever since i used the mimic i
haven't really been using summons at all
you didn't really beat the game if you
use summons
says probably some redditor
probably
i hate these guys
nice fencing skills bruh
oh a hoodie
church is everywhere you look i i live
in the midwest so yeah
absolutely
how
you just make your way down here
there's perfume
what fight is this
oh this is uh the zimmer zamor right
rats and dogs are the real bosses how
about birds
what's the hardest
like random thing to fight in the game
dogs
rats or birds
i'm saying birds 100
birds
ow
does nothing stagger anymore
[Music]
this fight's really cool
visually
howie
a lot of stutters today
[Music]
oh yeah you do that don't you
[Music]
i think we should uh whoa
oh my god
i got own
holy moly that thing didn't ever bleed
do they bleed maybe not
miyazaki was having a bad day when he
created the birds
in this game for sure
hold on hold on hold on
spire grace work on her
let's give it a shot
the fourth church america
said to me
fire pots throw the axe i don't want to
talk about throwing the axe oh that's
what we wanted to do
we wanted to do raduvia
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's what we're gonna do
later
wait i have a sacred tier
forgot about that
rolling forwards do i have fire grease
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay
we go again
epic
hmm
oh i thought it was gonna be the other
one
shoot
it is
yeah i plagiarized dr disrespect for
using the word yeah
it's the logic we're dealing with here
you know why i get
use
you know why i use the frenzy flame
ending you know those bird enemies
that's why
nice
holy subs thank you
thank you thank you
that was funny
um okay i think that's all the upgrades
we can get
around here
we can go to the misbegotten or
castlemore
thank you janak
appreciate it appreciate it i don't know
why i'm doing this
um i wanted to level up that's what
how much arcane do we need hold on
[Music]
we need 13. we're actually close to that
aren't we
oh thank you phillip that's really nice
of you to say
i'm glad you're enjoying it dude
i'm having fun i just want to get this
whole [ __ ]
dealt with and over
all right so how is this thing
jesus
okay
let's go see what our boys got for us
with this
what's the lore behind the cement balls
i have no idea
no clue
to me they're just balls
yeah i haven't been here in a while man
not for a while
oh i just need runes okay
let's pop some mollies
i i'm letting chat kind of choose i
remember last stream they wanted me to
use the reduvia so i'm going to go for
it
build wise like for the whole thing i'm
i'm not sure
have a good one bruno back already
yeah i could have sold those couldn't i
i'm kind of dumb
three where can i get a three
i can get a three and a four from eg
i know where to get a five that's that's
like some uh
caled stuff we're good
okay
let's go
let's go
if you press y you don't you leave the
menu when you lose runes neat
that's actually sick
i want to fight this uh this guy right
here real quick
and you guys are smart i just make
everything hard don't i
let's see how good this is
how far did this reach
not very far
now
what
okay
we're learning
how
this is not going well
[Music]
what
flail sucks
[Music]
guys the redundant balls
i'm getting owned
well that was good
i'm definitely hitting the horse more
than anything
[Music]
nothing
oh my god
this is so bad
it's taking forever
stop running away
it never stops attacking
where did that go
this guy would have died five minutes
ago if i had my uchi
look at that three consecutive attacks
there we go
damn
okay
let's not get hit
whoops
no not already freaked dude
[Music]
we got this i think
never mind
oh my god
roduvius sucks
oh if i was on a horse
all right let's see let's see the quick
difference here just real quick
check it
we got this immediately does
exactly
we just did
all that
for nothing
radio duvia op
where
all right let's see the difference
nice whiff
yeah i think this is a
just a weird instance where it's not
very good against this guy
got his booty
i just need to get gooder at the game
right
nerd
i shouldn't have called you that i'm
sorry
that hurts you by the way that hurts you
now
well that was a huge difference
so you know that hurts you
yeah i think that was just like a weird
instance where it wasn't very good
because he's on horseback
we got one level
we're going arcane
let's go arcane does dragon stuff and
bleed stuff right
let's go
also should i just like one
one hand this
wait how much do i have i kind of know
what i want to do
is patches still over here
he is
he has a parrying dagger
that would be kind of sick
kind of double dagger build
goddess booty
his name's bob
i think someone asked i should if uh i
would do lore on the knights cavalry i
don't really know much else besides what
i said in the morgot godfrey video where
we talk about the knights cavalry
i think that's that pretty much covers
it with them
hello again
um right here parrying dagger
that sounds kind of sick no cap
um
about the bandits
i had those bandits make a clean break
now they're all suppliers no good ones
survivors of the defeated army
work to the bone by their high and
mighty lord
only to be thrown out with the rubbish
thank you cheesy story everywhere
it is very unimaginable like not very
imaginative
wondering what's inside the treasure
chest
well
it's uh
nothing too special
just something i'm saving as thanks
for a very valuable customer
but then again
it would fetch some spectacular coin
and besides
no shot could
so if you go if you open this chest
it'll take you to the miss woods right
in front of a bear we don't want to do
that um
all right let's finally go
the lore of the parrying dagger or the
raduvia
let's look at both
sorry my brain blinked okay
let's see
jagged dagger with distinctive curb
blade used by the noble servants of the
lord of blood the stagger rips the flesh
as it enters inflicting blood loss with
sickening efficiency
efficiency efficacy efficacy a proud
testament to the success of its vicious
design
this weapon is perpetually coated in
blood flash of the wicked dagger it
doesn't really tell you lore interesting
interesting
and then the parrying dagger
a knife
with
curved hand guards
designed to parry trendy foes attacks
against them remasters of combat who
anticipate every enemy strike encounter
accordingly this weapon is all they need
heck yeah
okay
oh i didn't equip it
we are this is a very interesting build
so far
so that was a [ __ ] lock
man i wasn't using it right i feel
or that was just uh a
moment nice shot bro
nice shot bro
do we know at what point um
shibriri takes over yura
what though
what a shot
he he knew i was gonna jump
this is ridiculous
did you see that
oh this is not okay
what is this
god damn
[Laughter]
that is um
that's a lot
that that's a lot
man
eleanor
after
eleanor dies and he moves into the
mountains eleanor
why am i not remembering who eleanor is
or ellen nora
[Music]
no i bought the perry and dagger from
patches
so it's a pairing dagger and a reduvia
and it does this
that seems a little ridiculous right
i'm gonna go upgrade real quick
it bothers me too high quality it
bothers me so much that nothing is in
that
then room would you like to live
i just want to know if he was going to
leave
okay
you want to see real speed [ __ ]
well
i took you for day
we know why he says that every time like
is that a like is he trying is it trying
to tell us that he's losing his mind
already when he keeps like
misremembering that we were like just
here
because he does lose his mind toward the
end
nice
okay finally let's go
you find her after you do the part of
yours quest near the academy gate see
i've never done years quest lines so
this is this is where i'm gonna need
your help chat this is a this is a
community effort to figure out how we
can do this in one playthrough
it's gonna be fun
wow
do we fight these things
do we clear it out or do we run
let's see
this seems a little
not good
whoa i'm dead
that didn't go well
why were they so aggressive
all of them were attacking me at once
hold on sorry i'm reading something
[Music]
try again don't be shy we'll see
[Music]
this area is probably really hard with
just daggers
[Music]
sorry hold on
hi kappa
[Music]
jesus okay
so somebody sent me a link to this thing
we're dealing with
and
like someone someone asked on reddit to
ann caligan
can you explain how you own the writing
on a reddit theory it clearly states in
the reddit's user agreement that you
don't and some random dude said
have you even read it it literally
states users do retain ownership of
their content quoting you retain any
ownership rights you have in your
content but you grant reddit the
following license to use that content
i don't
he's reading that wrong
because that means that
if you like posted your book onto reddit
then you retain those ownership rights
you don't like just because you post it
on reddit doesn't mean it's ownership
copyright
right
that is very weird
he basically just sent me the
the same
thing that i said which is where you
don't own anything reddit does
i'm reading it wrong or him
he just said to this brandon i don't
know who this is but he sent a random
thing saying have you read it
it literally states users do retain
ownership of their content
and then he quotes you retain any
ownership rights you have in your
content he's just reading that wrong
right
because that means like
that doesn't mean that when you post
something
you have ownership right
weird why did why does he read that and
think that you do
you retain any ownership rights you have
in your content
what
how is he even reading that wrong like
that doesn't make jesus christ
i just i just wonder like how people are
so misinformed when they have the words
in their face
you know
i tried to parry a dog
because i've really been trying to
understand how and caligan can actually
think
can actually think what he's thinking
right i've been trying to understand it
just so i can see it from his point of
view
and it doesn't make sense
just sees what he wants to see i i guess
oh i can upgrade now
yeah i think he's just reading it wrong
which is unfortunate man like i just
feel bad about the whole [ __ ] thing
or like i just feel bad that they're
just reading [ __ ] wrong
oh i can spam this
what
since when do you do that
these daggers are really fun
all right let me try and parry one
i can spam it that is crazy
it's hard to tell who's attacking
nice
yup and then i have the crit hit to get
health back when i do that this is kind
of a cool build
can't bury that
dude this build is so fun holy [ __ ]
all right i'm gonna die trying to parry
these weird moves
i wish he went down the
wait
no
that would have been funny
yo what up dog
wow these are fun
holy crap this is cool with the option
to parry and spam a uh
like a arranged attack
as an option that is this is cool
okay sorry i wasn't reading um i'm an
old
game of thrones books
community theorem
in the community was r plus l equals j
because if you read the books you can
assume that even the first book even
r plus l equals j
it's because they yeah they read what
they want to hear
imagine if one of the first persons on
the internet posts the theory and claim
the ownership of r plus l plus j equals
j
i guess
how does someone copyright elden ring
lore like we aren't even trying to
uncover that stuff so that that's not
what that is not what in caligan is
trying to argue i think
he is trying to argue that the words
used
that he posted are his copyright which
he's just not right about
wow oh my god
this could be a really fun build
kyle have you noticed that everyone in
youtube chat is just way nicer than um
than twitch chat we do have bot problems
though
kyle attack and kill
i'd always recommend doing the hide user
kyle by the way
hide user works as well and then you can
just report it
so people were telling me last stream
that those are like pretty big on
youtube like those weird bots
it's very strange
you dead nope
is he gonna fall oh my
jesus
that
[ __ ]
what is my health at where is my health
bar
wow dude
close one okay
hi frost bites welcome good to have you
here man
what's the plan for eldon ring bling on
this build no clue we're going with the
flow
[Music]
rot dagger and roduvia i kind of like
the option to parry though
i i actually can't
i can't
see my health at all
check your status what does that mean
what is status
don't hit me i'll die if you do
bigger check oh you mean stats in the
game got it
got it
why does giga chad have clothes
good idea
options i mean here
what
what build you thinking anything chat
wants but i i really want to do this
dagger build it's kind of fun
oh wait can i not go back over here
oh there another way to get back in
oh i'm dumb now i know what you're
talking about
man
okay
i don't want to run through the castle
again
destroy
if so many accounts
thank you kyle
okay i guess we can't go back over there
and i have to run through the castle
again sick
because i have to i gotta talk to edgar
edgar
that's fine we'll just we'll just run
through no problem
there you go chat
you like what you see
no you can't summon tauren in the castle
yeah i think it's a fun playthrough it's
not like super serious i don't even know
if it's even possible but it's fun to
try
i thought i might as well do it live
get some help from chat
ew i could see the inside of his face
and thank you for all the subs guys
that's a lot of subs
today thank you
i could have just gone the lower way and
that would have been way easier oh well
your boyfriend named himself america's
tits
a man of true class
a real gamer
very nice
the plagiarized build there you go
boom boom boom boom
more than lore videos coming
i
yeah i i want to focus on streaming this
week
take a little break from the major
uploads
just kind of hang out
um but i am working on some more videos
yes
uh there's a face i've not seen before
nine edgar
warden of this castle as ordained by
lord godrick himself
but you can see how things have turned
out yeah terrible
they've all rebelled
they gave me good service or so i
thought but it seems it was all an act
foul creatures as i said and true enough
they're foul inside and out
i'm sorry to disappoint you
but whatever you come here to do
i'm afraid castlemore
won't hold much longer
take this by way of apology
thank you art i appreciate the kind
words man i see
from
arena thank you
i mean you're dead
but i can't leave yet
even if the castle should fall
this commander yeah i don't know what's
going on yannick
the one one thing is that people are um
people are misusing copyright a lot
right now
for some reason i don't know the i don't
know why that's the case
but i think the major thing here
especially in in the ann caligan like
thing that i'm dealing with right now
is that
i think the the main thing is that they
are completely misinformed
they believe something completely that
that just is not true
so
i i don't know what's up with that that
that's kind of the thing i've been
thinking about a lot because like i was
saying i
in some way i just feel bad for him
because he's just wrong
and he's he's so
he's so adamant about the truth that
he's trying to pull out of nothing
and he just thinks i'm lying my ass off
and and he can believe whatever he wants
to believe
but i didn't lie and but he just wants
to believe that i am
and then with all the copyright stuff
he's just not correct
he's wrong
but he he truly thinks that he's in the
right
these things are hard bro like god damn
edgar help me
oh god
and when you can't stagger these guys
they are crazy
people don't think the sun be like what
it is but if you think
it's because it's mistranslated
i don't know
that's what i mean it is almost sad
because do i want to
do i want to do any of this
no
but if he's going to like go as far as
to copyright strike my channel i will
sue him
and i don't i don't think that's my
fault
you know what i mean
i can sue him for a lot more than just
the copyright uh
false copyright claims he's doing
that thank you yannick i i think this
entire [ __ ] thing this in this entire
thing
is
he
thought that i took his his writing he
thought that i took his reddit comment
he can believe what he wants to believe
by that whatever
i didn't do it but he can believe
whatever he wants right
man these bots are crazy today
um
thank you kyle
i forget what i was gonna say now
but
i think his entire
like what he's been trying to do from
the word go
is intimidate me to just take the video
down
because it's similar to his and he just
wants his theory
that he believes truly believes that
it's just his which is crazy
i mean he'll he'll keep correcting
himself saying something like
i'm not copyrighting the theory i'm
copyrighting the words
it's like
it it got to a point where it's like
okay you are not
i i couldn't even talk to him anymore
because he just kept saying the same
thing over and over again
when we were dming so i was just like
okay i'm over it i sent you a con i sent
you a counter claim
there you go
so there it is
i yeah i've i feel like i've handled the
situation really well i'm just tired of
dealing with it you know i i just want
to make i want to make videos i want to
play elden ring i want to
not be
you know stressed about [ __ ] that i
don't need to be stressed about
it it just sucks
the whole thing sucks
he thinks
it was the theory that
it's a [ __ ] comment it was the gideon
go watch the most recent video it gives
you all the most
it gives you all the information
all right leonine
it's gonna be tough
oh god this is gonna be tough with this
build boys
i mean drawing the same conclusions
something that would bond people yes
usually but he thinks i stole his stuff
word for word which looking at what he's
talking about i was like holy [ __ ] this
is similar
and he just believes that i stole it
i didn't but he will never ever ever
believe that
so that's that's what he's truly mad
about is that he believes that i stole
it
and i'll tell him i didn't and he just
won't leave it like it's crazy
no no no we got this
i rolled both times and it did not do
nothing
[Music]
why am i crouched
bro this is tough
it's all about the bleed
if we can get the bleed off he's dead
i think um before we start using the
daggers we need to up our arcane and
then we'll be good
until then i'm going to use the uh
the katana because he's dead right here
pretty much
you know he just wants attention right
he posts
and is very active in reddit but it's
kind of funny the way he sees things
i that's what i think
i mean he
people keep linking me what he's saying
on reddit because he's still talking on
reddit like even today and he's just
telling people like i own the rights to
my comment
and i just don't get it
i just don't get it
give me my roomies
i rolled
i almost killed me
this fight is awesome i love his moveset
his moveset is so cool
[Music]
well that was bad
[Music]
bruh
yeah i love the unsheathed unsheathed is
really good
uncheap
crouching tiger hidden deck
church are true all right arcane
one level
did i not pick up my rooneys
i don't i only have one level off of
that that ain't even worth
that even worth dog
that ain't even worth bruh
okay
let's go back to irena
i think we can go to stormville castle
yeah the boss is pretty low level but
it's still a really cool uh
it's freaking awesome i like it
greener
how could this be
my daughter deserved better
who fought lies
with me
i chose duty over my daughter's safety
and
that is how faith is answered
i'll find them
the foul
see i've i thought we talked about this
earlier but i find this area to be the
most boring area in the game actually
rest assured
arena but i do like the miss begotten
boss fight
that is that is a cool part i'll find
them
the foul will hunt them down
i don't think she did fake her death
i don't think she's faking it
okay
stormville right i don't think we can do
anything else
i like castlemore yeah
what makes it boring um there's not a
ton to do in the entire area just down
to the south i mean
and the way it looks like it's always
raining it's a little bit like dry
looking
it's about it like it's not boring like
it's it's cool just compared to the rest
of the game
no i'm saying
i think that's switched hands yeah
and now i have this
no no no
switch hands
okay cool
oh still a parry did i not switch hands
interesting okay
i feel like i need some clothes
or their sisters could be
i think the shiburi grapes took over her
body
jake posted the video sunday two hours
later and caligan already asked if he
could claim copyright posts on
plagiarism thread i mean he was asking
for legal advice in the legal advice
subreddit where one person told him yes
it is copyrighted
and the rest of them were saying no it's
not
you're tarnished aren't you
i would advise against taking the main
gate into the castle
it's tightly guarded by hardened old
hands you guys know this guy stalks you
through the whole place
right here
the guards don't know about it
you'll breach the castle undetected
creepy af
yes
i'll show you what i mean
you're just the kind of tarnish that i
like
i pray for your success
i pray for your thick fat
i can't kill him chat we're doing a
questline thing uh duh
duh chat
come on
well i can't hide gigger right
nope
you can kill him
i just won't
i really don't want to deal with these
birds bro
he wants your body heck yeah dude
you guys seen giga chad look at this
body
oh yeah
because if you kill shabiri he mentions
that he cannot die like some sort of
weird spirit yeah he like uh
he goes from body to body which is
pretty cool okay so here's what i mean
by this
holy bots
so look right there nobody there right i
like uh i can't point it out like right
on top of this right on top of my head
here
nothing right you see that bird but on
this ledge right on top of my head
nothing right we're gonna go up here
[Music]
see here's where this is gonna be good
okay we're gonna go in here
this is fun
check this out
i think i went far enough
see a difference
it's just sitting there now i didn't
even have to rest or anything
there he is
stalking me
dead bird
there's a squirrel out my window chat
wow
there he is
oh oh
yeah you're scared huh oh great
i'm glad you're here
just a small reward i was saving it for
you yeah either he knows we're gonna
kill godric
or he wants to take our body for
grafting
thanks for the grace mimic man it's like
getting a mushroom from bach good now
let's be on our way shall we
wouldn't want the guards to spot you
aren't the claws in stormville like in
the bottom
hop along with you
what
isn't that creepy though that he
actually stalks you
oh he's also that he
that guy is also the guy that shuts you
in the in the door up here
a lot of people said it was patches
it's definitely gostic gostak however
you say his name
every moon you take i'll be watching you
i'm pulling out the uchi chat
for this freaking guy in here
yep if you kill a gostik before going in
the room the door does not shut
but i didn't so here we go
we'll get the claws
foreign
used to have dialogue after you kill
godric where he mentions he is the son
of godric
gostick's the son of goger
neat
curb sword talisman that's pretty neat
rusty key
that's cool i haven't looked into cut
dialogue before
i don't know how much we can just like
look into cut dialogue because they
probably took it out for a reason like
maybe they just didn't want it to be
true anymore you know
like want it to be the case if that
makes sense
i do see a resemblance though like his
face
is kind of the same as all these uh guys
that look exactly the same does that
mean all these people are the sons of
godric
has godric just been uh
having all these kids
that would make this place so [ __ ] up
oh it should go down some yep yep yep
no okay i don't know
we're digging we're digging
we're seeing what's going on
[Music]
okay how do i get a gossip
to uh show up right here
what do i have to do
that was unnecessary but cool
i believe these are the claws
you're
let's see
89
blood blood loss 60
and then blood loss 51
101 and i leveled it up twice
hmm
i don't get the cool attacks anymore
though
like i don't know about you guys but i
have never seen this before where you do
this
like that's wicked right this is nuts
and if we get our arcane up to get that
blood loss going faster oh my goodness
guys don't click on the links don't
click on the links i got it
i got
it you're all smart
there we go
there we go i don't know what's going on
with bots
bots are by adam kaye
bots are bad
pairing against crucible knights is
helpful
that's why i got a perry knife
okay let's get it
yeah i did see that you can uh parry all
these knights pretty easily
you got to get the timing down obviously
but it's doable
yeah does anyone know how i can get
gostic to spawn down there
i've never been able to do that
them bots took our jabs
we tickered
okay
giga chad
i am the best
first try
i'm bro gonna die
yep we just gotta if we can get this
damage up boys
and uh a quicker bleed proc we this
build could be lit
i think gossip just spawns down there
after he locks you i mean what he wasn't
there so
i don't think so
fire grease
uh oh
i did not mean to do that
hmm
i'm just breaking stuff for fun at this
point
[Music]
i i want to go back and check right now
i don't think he's going to be there
though
because you don't have to rest or
anything for him to move
which is already weird
very weird
oh that idiot
you want to eat the fire grease
yeah he's not there
i'm pretty sure he's right here
i'm gonna check and see if he's outside
just for the
i just want to see
yeah he's still over there
so
hmm
i wonder what triggers him
[Music]
wow
i appreciate all the follows on twitter
by the way guys i don't know if anyone
in here is doing that but um gotten a
lot of them today so thank you
maybe
you just fall what a noob
this is scary
bye buddy
what
thank you ollie i'm glad you like him
i'll be watching you
yeah i i probably do need to rest
wait is he there yeah he's still there
bro dang all right
let's go to the next part where we rest
and then we'll come
either check
we'll check both spots see what's going
on
because this this could be finicky
because we don't at least with the last
one we didn't have to rest
wiki says opening gate may stop the
triggers for him moving inside the tower
okay i didn't open the gate
so i will not do that
yeah i started watching videos and
you're pretty good
but put some perspective into the
gameplay perfect
that's what we're looking for
nice
good to hear
i do like the music in here
okay
level at once putting an arcane
boom
thank you joel i saw that thank you
i have a i haven't really tweeted very
much in my time as a creator i would
like to tweet but
you know when you tweet and you get like
one like it makes you not want to tweet
maybe my tweets suck that could very
well be the case
all right this isn't going well
god the timing is hard in this game
with all the different enemies
i mean i was gonna say that twitter
seems like it's dying
but then elon bought it so
yeah i mean i'm not like i don't really
care i just don't tweet very much
just don't like feel like it
i heard someone running
ooh
yeah maybe we don't do that
is that supposed to revive twitter no i
i don't know
maybe
hi
chad i'm kind of hungry today and i kind
of want to have a cheat day
if i were to go get food what should i
get
which i don't know if i've told everyone
this but i have lost like 40 pounds in
the last like two years
so i've been pretty good with the uh
with that
sushi
oh god oh wait we need to go check
gostick i keep forgetting that we need
to do that
the no free speech free speech platform
hot wings pizza is always epic
i'm scared
congratulations on losing the weight
thank you
i wasn't like out of shape i would say i
was like
i worked out all the time
but i ate a lot of bad food so i just
weighed a lot if that makes sense
so
trying to see if he's down there
so i was just like big right
but then i wanted to slim down
and we're down 40 pounds
just poggers
he's not there chet
i don't know what triggers gossip to go
right there
five guys we don't have very many five
guys around here and they're really
expensive aren't they
thank you thank you appreciate it
i just gotta check
we're doing our uh thorough research
he is not there confirmed he is not
there
not there
la oh my goodness
how is living in l.a do you like it
i've never been
depends on the area and where you want
to eat well i'm just taking all
suggestions
i also may just go eat carrots
baja blast you mean the best drink at
taco bell of course
wildfires are pretty freaky yeah
i have family that lives in danville and
family that lives in um napa
and they are they love it there but it's
very um
very expensive and the wildfires are are
scary
uh excuse me
okay maybe now he's triggered
somehow
yes i love chinese food
i like all food
unfortunately i am allergic to peanuts
f's in the chat for that
i am allergic to peanuts let me get rid
of this real quick sorry
and bots are nuts
f's in chat for
allergic to peanuts
all right i'm giving up on it i don't
know how to get him to move
i mean i would eat vegan food
or i probably can't
i've eaten at five guys and had no
allergic reaction which is very weird
right and i am
very allergic to peanuts
ooh general sal orange chicken fried
rice okay where do i get it from
just a local chinese place or like panda
express
aren't carrots vegan
i think i just like carrots
i don't i so here's here's what i've
been doing to lose 40 pounds chat just
uh um
because i was
222 pounds uh this time
uh in 2019 right
and now i weigh uh like 180 180
i think i was 180 yesterday
so it's around 40 pounds and the thing
that i've been doing that works so well
for me
is i eat one time a day
i eat a pretty decently sized meal one
time
and then and then the rest the rest of
the day i drink water i can drink coffee
um and then if i have a craving for
something i just eat popcorn
and that that has worked
wonders for me
so so for me i'm five foot nine i'm not
like a super tall guy so
um i just went to caloriedeficit.com
and it will tell you like okay how much
weight do you want to lose this is how
many calories you're supposed to eat in
a day so for me
i if i wanted to lose 40 pounds by this
time
i needed to eat 1500 calories a day in
only 1500 calories so the thing about
that is i can eat whatever i want right
but as long as it's under 1500 calories
then it's fine like i could go and get a
1 500 calorie mcdonald's meal but i will
not eat anything the rest of the day
if i eat that much
does that make sense
thyroid tumors that is no fun i'm sorry
to hear that
that sucks
irenia is what makes rodericka leave the
hold
i i believe you're right emma yes
i just don't know how to get gostock to
move
you're good kyle have a good day at work
fasting in the morning
until about three to four and having a
decent meal is the best way i
that's what worked for me like it come
totally depends on the person totally
depends on like what you know your your
body type is and and all that stuff
right
but for just for me one meal a day
the other thing i notice about that is
when i started doing the just one meal a
day under 1500 calories
i stopped getting hungry
like as often because my body got used
to the fact that okay we're going to eat
1500 calories at this time of the day
and then we're gonna we're basically
gonna fast for 23 hours
pretty much
yep yep
popcorn low calorie
it create you know you it takes a while
to eat
it is uh
yeah
it it
it holds back the cravings that i may
have
yeah that's intermittent fasting and
it's very aggressive fasting so like
usually people will fast for like 16
hours or eight hours i fast for 23 hours
in the day
so that that's a lot
what is the lore on your channel uh
the
lore of elden ring you i have an elder
ring lore tab if you want to see that
on my channel
die bird
these are the hardest enemies in the
game i'm being very careful
yeah
i'm dead
like what am i
i hated that okay
what's your dog's name my dog's name is
joy
she is a mix of a
golden lab and a german shepherd
and i love her and she is awesome
and i rescued her
joy j-o-y
she's a girl
and she's a she's a rescue
roger
what a player
ah
nice to meet you youtube pleasure's mine
is he just taller than me sorcerer as
you might have guessed
i'm looking for not by much
here in the castle when i'm not
hot-footing it from the troops that is
but enough about me
what are you doing here in stormdale
castle i'll check that out
i don't think i've seen that tarnish
hunters you know
they sacrifice our kind
for grafting
not exactly a place i'd stroll into
without a purpose in mind
i'm here to defeat godric i see
here to challenge godric and lay your
hands upon a great rune yeah he about to
get the death white then i take it
the guidance of grace
well
enjoy it while you can
i'm tarnished yeah jace i don't think
i've ever come in the way i just did
that was weird of this guidance for the
longest time
still
i won't forget how it felt when i first
came here to the lands between
i'm privy to a few magical battle arts
would you care to learn one as a fellow
tarnished once guided by grace i'd love
to help you out if it please
what does he have uh glenstone pebble
oh the spinny thing
and then the greatsword okay
my parents won't let me have a dog i'm
16 years old
uh just wait till you move out and just
go rescue a dog i got joy for 90.
which in the grand scheme of things
is very inexpensive to have a best
friend forever
is it implied he loses his legs he gets
death blighted so his legs are infected
how do we get back up there actually
hold on um
let's see
yo what up brody how you doing man good
to see you
yeah i'm pioneering new paths yeah i'm
gonna copyright the paths that i'm
taking chat so
don't use them okay
i'm sorry
okay where did you say this path was
where what
did i refine it or am i tripping
let me go back over here
oh i gotta do this is this fire wait
what did he just do
bird
path near the birds okay i'm looking i'm
looking i'm looking i'm looking
i'm here baby
it's probably right here right
this reminds me of dark souls 3 where
you get lifted up by those things
you're right
ooh
do i fall into this
what
never been here by the way oh my
goodness
what the flip dude
got a shield
wow what is this
this seems sketchy
i'm dead
why am i alive
no
no
no
pain
where am i
that just looked like it was gonna break
bro
why are we alive dude are these plants
that thick bro
what the is that a crucible night
oh shoot
here i'll go through the air i'll come
back though to get that thing
that didn't work
this is weird
i should not have done that
have i hurt him yet
okay
well we need to do it again anyway
used a bow i might pull out the uchi
katana because we still haven't leveled
our arcane enough to warrant this build
i got owned
now i'm going to die to the birds
because i'm impatient and want to go
back immediately
call it epsom chat i'm dead i'm gonna
die
i have some chat i'm dead
all right i think we're good unless they
can come down here then i'm dead
leave me alone nerd
almost died to fall damage
okay never mind we're good
okay
this is sick though come here
come here
that wasn't worth it at all
anyway
do i just fight this crucible knight
will you get something for defeating him
okay
try hard pants
ready to go
oh
freaking tail
all of that
all of that perfect dodging
to just die in one combo
welcome to eldon ring
oh welcome to elden ring
all right
we got this
no
oh my god
close one
chad i ain't gonna cap i'm gonna run
past him
i'm gonna keep it uh a hundred p on a
stack squishy
i might run past this guy
why do i feel like i'm falling way
longer
i'm also gonna put my pants back on
what's this
what
damn okay damn damn
what is over here
oh
this is where this takes you
sorry i'm looking for other paths
you get the tail
what
is this supposed to be some kind of
shortcut
that genuinely scared me oh my god
what is this
stay
i'm going to cheese you sir
i'm here
i'm here
yes
are you okay
yes come this way
i'm come
i do not bite
dang it
i don't think it's gonna work what is
the point of this area
i guess to just do a wrap around back
over here okay
neat
my mom wants to watch a movie chat but i
do want to get to godric so we're going
to go right to godric now
i'm gonna watch a movie with my mom
i love my mom
okay
she wants to watch a movie called the
ghost story
i've not heard of it
oh we will come back for him
man going this way instead
of the
main gateway is obnoxiously slower
sounds kind of scary
yeah it probably is
probably is um
yeah
we'll see
i don't know
yeah she said she's done with work
so she wants to watch
a movie
well she asked me to and i said okay
because i i only like streaming for two
to three hours at a time
this room is really cool okay
we need to clear out this entire castle
one day
and just a look at everything
to godric
oh we need to talk to feli lou first
though that's right
she's i know where she is
we got this we got this
[Music]
cheat
shoot
they had to have purposely made the horn
in this game like funny
must have
i may go and upgrade my weapons as well
nope let me sit thank you
we can also grab um
this right
here two smithing stone ones which is
pretty big value
and there's one more right here
i think it's a smithing two
two of them
and then that's the area to the um
to godwin
or his corpse pretty much
so
let's go back up here we'll talk into
philly lou and then we'll go upgrade and
then fight godric and then we'll be done
sound like a plan
the plan has been made
oh yeah we're doing everything every
single quest line
we're gonna try to
thank god
i don't know if i'll ever be done with
this game
yeah be proud
you were a fine warrior
your only mistake was your choice of
muster
let the winds lift you
to a higher place
that is such a good mindset
well who do we have here
tarnished are you
co-op in this game is so much fun
so much fun
tarnished and warrior like you
i'm here by decree of my father
how utterly repellent this is
this grafting of godric's ill befits a
lord
he's tainted the very winds
facts if you intend to challenge godric
i ask you call upon me
same or must same with his deeds
i'm certain father would permit me ate
the fight
okay i think that's all our dialogue
apologies oh no it's not but i've idled
long enough
as fellow tarnished we must each follow
our own guidance
down whatever road takes us to the
throne of elden lord
okay that's definitely it
is nafeli your
boo nafeli's hot man no cap
she's hot
yeah yeah when whenever you're not
getting disconnected yeah it's it's it's
pretty good okay let's go upgrade
real quick if we can
and then uh
we'll beat up godric who i find to be
one of the easier bosses in the game
move set wise i think it's pretty easy
to dodge except for like one attack
where he like kind of scrapes the ground
one all right well that's it fair enough
let's go
supposedly stabilizing co-op sweet
all right nephili i'm calling you in
just for the lore aspect of it
looks like a bunch of scribbles dog
godric is way easier than uh than than
margaret a hundred percent
oh my controller dc'd there we go
mighty dragon
directed
yeah i'm offline
deliver me unto
greater heights
well
guys phil mccracken commented saying you
might be legally okay but you do copy
other people's work and it's pretty lame
okay
thanks man
i command thee
i am the lord of all that is golden
yeah these golden nuts
ah
my controller's bugging oh my god okay
we're good
[Music]
so
so
that was pretty good
sounds like the name of a legal expert
yeah definitely
he even said i'm legally fine but he
still thinks i copy other people's work
which is just like i'm never gonna make
everybody happy am i it's just not a
possibility
of
whatever
here's my stupid opinion
yeah that bleep rock was nutty
[Music]
one of the best lines in the game right
there bear witness
nafeli you want to help
oops
how do you get away from that
no i died no
i thought i jumped
no
i was good i was too confident
get him to philly oh man
i was too confident i just kept standing
there because you can just like wait for
him to come
man
no i'm on pc there is a lot of
stuttering going on today
tragedy all right let's get it
can't parry very barely any bleed let's
get it
oh yeah
such a cool attack
nah we don't need spirit ashes we're
good i just messed up on the last one
why do i feel like i'm doing no damage
randomly
okay
okay this is going bad
what is happening
why am i doing no damage the heck
[Music]
all right nathalie's got the rest
i believe in the philly lou
[Music]
let's go to belly
not looking good for her not gonna go
not gonna lie
close one
not not even close
let's go to philly
[Music]
no
[Music]
she died
sad
sad
oh the delays in this game are freaking
nuts dude
okay
what is going on
it's gonna be a close one
oh
okay
let's go
i like video ideas
no you won't get locked out of a request
line if she dies she's just a summon
there
godric who
who mega lol godric who mega lol
gigi and we got god stuck
what a pathetic excuse for a lord you
were
i will craven to the
bone pushing me about like that and
after all that crafting
where did that get you
you bump
on me
godric you filthy slug feel it
feel it
feel my bloody wrath
man
okay
oh
hello what's the lord behind the godric
soldier boss in the cave at the start of
the game i think it was just a soldier
for the tutorial
was always looking down i thought it'd
be cool if you made a video on crumbling
pharaoh missoula and how to how it got
to that point that is a good idea
i could look into that absolutely
that's a very good idea i had an ugly
heart yo it's smoke what's up man
countenance how you doing met the
ugliest events eh
saw your video today good job here if
you want to chat and we've we've been
talking about it all day it's it's been
uh
it's been an interesting few days man i
just want the whole thing to be over
i really do because this this guy is
just
very
interesting person i suppose
thanks caustic
but yeah that that's uh that's all i'm
gonna progress on today but i will uh
talk about it a bit at the end here
for a bit
but we made some good progress we got
all the way through castle mourn and
then stormville today so that's good
that is good
but i do want to go watch a movie with
my mom she wants to watch a movie called
ghost story that she heard about so
it does sound kind of nice
but uh yeah there's this whole deal with
this
with this guy from reddit has been
very exhausting
because
this person just truly truly truly
believes truly believes that they are in
the right and that they they own rights
to when they to the words that they use
when they comment on reddit
and uh
he's just not right so i just think he's
misinformed i don't think he's a bad
person i think he's just misinformed and
is just defending himself
in a way that he thinks he needs to he's
just not right so
in a way i feel kind of bad but
i also don't because he
started a legal dispute with me so
now
if he wants to really take it that far
then we will
and i will do everything i can to clean
him out at that point
it's a complete delusion well somebody
somebody sends me is it a good film
jessica i'm kind of excited she said
it's about like
it's like a wholesome movie not a scary
movie
um
i mean i very well may have told him to
[ __ ] off i mean i talked i talked with
him in dms and he is just extremely
adamant about the truth right he wants
he just wants to me to be like hey i
stole all your content um
i lied about it and i suck that's
basically what he wants me to say
and i can't say that because it's not
true but he's never gonna believe that
even i was taken back by how similar my
script was like i i have my script
i have it
like i i just it's crazy and looking at
my script compared to what he wrote in a
comment that i never even saw
uh he believes that i stole it so it's
like okay i mean i guess we just like to
use the same words when we
when we're describing the same thing
which
i think right there kind of
already tells you what's going on but
whatever man i mean that is just
if he is entitled to his opinion on what
he wants to believe but of course it
does not warrant a copyright strike
against my channel
in my videos that is crazy
um people on reddit are telling him
that
he does own legal right to what he posts
on reddit
and
you know there's people
he'll always just i mean he sent me the
links to why he thinks that
when in turn
it tells him why he's wrong if he just
kept reading
which is
which is weird
is he young i i have no idea i don't
know anything about this person besides
their name on reddit
but
i don't know
the fact that they just protrude
confidence with this entire thing
is really weird because
he thinks he's just completely right
and
i find it a little sad and a little
scary
that he's this misinformed
that he truly does believe this i mean
this is what happens when people spread
false information
and uh tell each other things that just
aren't true and then other people choose
to believe them it's uh
it could be seen as arrogance
but you know you know yeah exactly so
it just sucks
no i wanted to talk about at the end of
the stream smoke you're fine
i appreciate all the support from
everybody i really do
i really do
i'm not sure jessica she just kind of
told me about it and texted me saying
hey let's watch a movie i'm done with
work and i'm like okay
so
your laugh is so snuggly wuggly okay
thanks man
uh i tend to follow pretty wholesome
channels like sinclair lore
like sinclair from dark souls
there might be a channel i haven't heard
of i read it on the internet so it must
be true exactly so
i just don't
i
i don't want to feel bad but i'm always
going to because that's just how i
always feel about these things i hate it
i
hate it when people don't like me
i hate it when people think i did
something wrong when i never have any
intention to do anything wrong ever
and they're just like it and he proved
it right away that he just wanted to
attack me to belittle me to defame me to
do whatever to scare the [ __ ] out of me
and then he felt so confident from his
reddit post that was taken down for
harassment by the way which i can sue
him for if he decides to go through this
i can counter sue him
um
he is going to
uh he felt so confident from all of
those people on reddit just telling him
misinformation that i think that's
what's changing all of this here so it's
just kind of a scary situation
about just like internet communities
for me
so
i don't know
i just want this whole thing to be over
with um he has i believe eight more days
to
provide evidence to youtube that he's
taking legal action against what we're
doing
against what he's doing or copyrighting
my channel if he doesn't do that then
the video will just will just be put up
um if he does decide to take it take it
to court i will absolutely take it to
court um i will clean him the [ __ ] out
and i will counter sue him
for harassment defamement
illegal use of copyright in the us
and on youtube
um
and hopefully get him taken off of
youtube wherever the [ __ ] he is if he is
so
that's what's going on
and i really don't hope it i really
don't hope that it comes to that but if
it does
that's what's gonna happen
i just hate this because i think he's
just really jealous
and he's taking it so far to take it
take it to a legal thing
you know he's taking it so far to make
this a legal action that just is like
he i i believe he misused the copyright
system to scare me
into just taking down the video because
he believes that i took his his writing
so
he can believe whatever he wants on that
i didn't but he can believe whatever he
wants that still doesn't mean that he
can copyright strike my channel that's
the whole thing
so i'm out of here chat i appreciate all
the support i had a great time today
it's so much fun streaming on youtube i
like streaming on youtube a lot um
yes
i will see you all probably tomorrow
maybe the next day
around the same time in the morning
stream for two three hours and we'll
we'll just continue into lear there any
of the lakes and probably the academy
so
that's where we're going next i
appreciate y'all
thank you so much again
i'm out of here
have a great rest of your day bye guys
thank you thank you thank you boy